what benefits would an MMA fighter get  employing the liver King diet I think  this one's pretty straightforward most  MMA fighters are already expressing a  high and more dominant form but at this  level it's a fraction of a percentage  that's going to get them what they  ultimately want right so if you're not  eating liver if you're not eating balls  for breakfast if you're not eating bone  marrow if you're not stacking the Sun  and the Earth if you're not putting down  your goddamn phone so that you can  connect and put yourself into a  parasympathetic state so that you can  express a higher more dominant form then  you're leaving something on the table  you're sleeping on your potential how  much better could you be in life  a lot better never getting out